friends on house bill 533
[Music]
so we should reference 287d three
now representative ames you have another
yeah the new language
added by the senate conservative
background
men's 287-d colon 11.
3 and essentially changes three
so that the lottery commission is the
upfront agency to do
the investigations that still
role for the attorney general in the
decision making
right in 287-d
11 after roman
the expenses incurred by the attorney
general
doing those background investigations
which it had been doing
may be charged back as but shall be a
that authorizes the attorney general's
costs to be charged back
switching to the lottery commission
incurring those costs
the statute needs to pick up the change
i think
in four and there's a similar problem
in five uh this is a roman 5
the 287-d
which allows the attorney general to
acquire
the by subpoena or otherwise the
as needed for the investigations and
again as the attorney general versus the
letter we're switching over to the
lottery commission but we're not giving
the lottery commissioned the tools and i
think
at least that's what it looked like to
me i haven't looked closely at this but
i'm just flagging this
obviously an easy fix
we all would have agreed to go forward
with the
switch of the background investigation
responsibility to
i think it looks to me like it would
need to be fixed
maybe maybe there's some other provision
in the statute somewhere
that would enable the lottery commission
to charge back
and to do the uh stuff he was calling in
our witnesses
but i don't know of that representative
yeah as far as the charging the expenses
of the investigation the lottery
commission has full authority to set its
own fees
so i would expect they would simply
adjust their application fee to cover
the expected cost of the investigation
that's a normal process for licensing
agents
the i don't know about the subpoenas
it may be covered under if you look at
peyton one of the side by side roman two
it says the division shall have such
civil and
administrative powers as necessary to
affect the purpose of this chapter
including the power to receive
intelligence upon applicants
to investigate any suspected violations
uh i'm not a lawyer but that sure seems
to be that that would
whether the costs of an investigation
would correspond
with the existing fee structure and
could be dealt with that way i don't
know
i i would think it would be better if it
could be managed within this conference
committee to do a straight fix
and uh and add the lottery commission in
both
sub-sections unless somebody has some
reason not to do that
it's an easy thing to fix it just it
makes it
more awkward to get to the closure of
[Music]
and certainly but you've given the
iteration of clearly indicates they have
supreme
problems but if you if you think that it
would be better to explicitly cause it i
if we weren't making other changes i
might say
well it's already there but since we are
making changes to correct the reference
we might as well
actually get the language clearly that
i think it's not going to be that much
because you understand what you want to
change
the way you do is run down to ols they
were all
down there yeah they have them all down
there yeah and
you know other than taking the final
vote unless
[Music]
attorney general or the lottery
commission
as applicable
[Music]
you don't have this language i
understand i'm looking at the statute
which i printed out last night
and so five says in any investigation
conducted pursuant to paragraph three
the attorney general and then i would
introduce the same language
he's not even paying attention
so just for the record griffin
legislating
what i have done is after talking with
representative major
in center guide is that i've at least
drafted an amendment of the os
in both your names um to
change references in the bill
from rsa 287 to rsa287d
or less can't exactly turn around in
another five minutes
so i'm hoping to get that amended soon
if there's another amendment
we need to have it physically in our
hands
right
[Music]
yes
she's
on the list uh we had friends set but
fred is being replaced by
uh representative genevieve um
fred has a mental issue that's fine it's
like
late afternoon they still haven't
they're trying to schedule a
you know as long to get involved
so um so fred
is not with us but so um
obviously this book this bill was about
sportsbook and
we all remember we we passed sports
betting back in 2019
uh that session uh
and the bill uh
there were two things that uh well that
we're gonna be discussing that relate to
that bill
was the uh the tier two issue and i
think we all agree on the tier two issue
that tier 2 can only currently be played
[Music]
vets can only be placed on maps
but not in the physical locations this
bill changes that to
be able to do the tier two bet and the
physical locations
so that's that we both agree on
both sides uh when we passed the bill
we passed it with a limitation of ten
locations
this amendment this representative
langsmann and
bill bill took that
and made it unlimited but in the house
ways it means
uh and we're unanimous on this
bipartisan we renounce that
you know two years isn't quite enough to
see
how this is going to take off and how
you know how many locations what kind of
demand there really is for these
physical locations so we we kept we put
the 10
back in in our amendment and then it
went over to the
took the 10 out and made it unlimited
so that's where that's the issue we're
going to be discussing
one of my arguments in the house ways
and needs was
that you know and i've i've talked to
the guys in manchester and i've talked
to the guys at
zebra and you come to find that there's
a bit of a risk
being a physical location and that
there's a risk because
of the way betting happens so
part of my thinking is that that you
know if we're trying to attract
they're gonna they're gonna be taking a
risk to do this and
they want they want to know that someday
this could be in 50 locations around the
state and
cutting them to fire you know i i'm all
for free enterprise i'm all for
about mother market talk and i talked to
charlie the other day he has no
no position on this of course but i said
well where are we
i i wanted the update so obviously we
have
see brooke in manchester um
who's in play we got three in play we've
got salem
berlin or interested
and then the communities because this is
the opt-in thing
about it i saw those and then we have
nashua but nashua has he hasn't voted
yet
so that community hasn't voted yet so in
two years
we've attracted five two that are
three that are interested so it's fine
so our position is
you know if there's ultimately the
demand
you know we you know what's the rush for
us to open it up
um you know if we think this demand we
can follow bill
down the road to say okay well let's
expand this to 15 or 20
whatever or make it unlimited um
so that's and again it was a 24 nothing
vote out of our ways and means and it
was on consensus
so simply stated that's it uh but again
and i purposely talked to to uh charlie
a couple days ago just to get the latest
update on where we are
and that was the latest update basically
the same update he gave me a couple of
months ago
basically the known movement on on
berlin or
or uh salem
was uh did you know if they were waiting
on
this legislation i don't know i didn't
ask them that i should
they don't know you mean other parts of
this legislation
they wouldn't be waiting on this because
they're not acting on it you know
they're not acting that's what they said
are they not acting waiting to see if
there's going to be a proliferation of
similar yeah right again that's my
theory
there's a risk of i was gonna invest in
this i noticed that there was a risk
i understand that how many books we can
have
physical locations you know
that's just me and i and i think our our
committee agreed that you know let's
let's just wait and see and see what the
market does
before we jump into opening this up and
the other thing is
i always say this about bills it's only
been two years
we we passed this bill with the premise
that there'll be ten locations
okay at least initially you know what i
mean and now here we are two layers
later
we're gonna we're gonna change that you
know let's let's let the body be
you know cold first you know before we
we start changing is there a correlation
between opening up to tier two
and the number of locations that's a
good question too
i think that may be a helpful thing
i mean i i heard from the manchester
ramsey wrote that
they're cons they're they're very upset
that they have bodies in their seats
right yeah and then and the game is
going on
and there's some people that like to be
physically making bets with other people
around you know it's there
but they're concerned that's what we're
all agreeing on tier 2 i think is that
then they fill out their phones to pay
you know what next next quarter
who's going to score the most points has
to be done on the on the app
not on physically there
and the facilities don't get any share
of that
revenue because it's being done on the
app it's not done
by them so all those bets they don't get
money for
you know any you know small amount
whatever they get so
um so again our position is
what's the rush and uh
you know i'll leave it up to you you
respond to that
well what's the rush what's the what's
the
seabrook's in full operation yes very
much
so they were good now
just it was the first place right going
on
the governor go there initially yeah
they were first but they were very close
they opened both about the same time
so of the ten that have been appropriate
how many how many are actually playing
as we speak
that's the point then i asked charlie
the other day i said
how many other applications have been
filed right
or interest not even applications who
else has expressed interest
salem berlin location right and
and uh in nashville now charlie would
he would love to see locations in the
bigger locations in the bigger
markets there was also
a situation in nashville where another
casino is being developed
right right now that's that's boston
billiards
i think it's worth the wait for the
possibility of just looking to expand
i'm sure that they would love this up
this this entity as part of their
package
if the if the situation the sale of them
gets right it ever gets resolved
so
they're not beating down the doors it's
been two years you know i'm getting down
the doors
you're right that maybe they are waiting
for this
legislation to change to say
you know that they can do the tier two
betting um
uh again we all agree that yeah that
that's
if we're gonna do it we should have the
act version
the same as the location
there is no downside
we only have two operating and two
looking
three both three possibly
so
unless there's some harm that comes from
yeah
french
daniel's daniel's comments were
that he thinks it's unconstitutional
always done in the house because it was
either the anti-gambling people
or the or the constitutional you know or
the
free market people and so
add them all up that didn't want casinos
we'd never pass
i mean for different reasons for a lot
of reasons
and there was no way that we were going
to say we're going to open it you know
because it's terrible gaming you can see
we're getting that way but well that's a
whole lot
let's hold that but but there was always
guys that said well why only one person
why only two casinos you know we had a
bill
let's have slot machines in every every
store that wants a slot machine
i think but again i go back to my theory
it's a theory i don't i can't prove this
logic i said but if i'm a businessman
i tonight so i'm going to invest in
sports but then we're going to take this
sports book we're going to split it up
you know such a number of people that
want a bet
it's just going to shrink there's only
so many betters in new hampshire
i mean also the border i mean one thing
we know is that seabrook is picked up
you go i was there i dragged my wife
there for kentucky derby
she goes we want to go i said listen go
over replace the bed
you look at the parking lot most you
know
over half the plates in massachusetts
they come up close
so um but anyway i i just
yeah i believe free markets too and i i
i could i can envision senator daniel
saying what he said
right uh does the heart either work
[Music]
because the markets already seems to be
talking that
you know they're not they're not banging
on the doors to invest in these
but on the other hand if we say it's
unlimited
that why would i want to
invest in something like this and
there's risk
when we can take the the population and
split it
uh of potential betters and spread it
over 20 locations
i don't know how far would a potential
better bill
but you know i wonder if that number 10
came out of 10 cities
back when we did this this build that
led to this
wall sports betting
in ways it means it was a new and
complicated subject so we set up
a subject
which i shared right right i think uh
representative and you were part of that
yeah we had a good working group
through all the issues and this one came
up what about the number of
they think there was consensus as i
recall
this was a new activity
and that
shouldn't just jump in without
limitations
this was true in other parts of the
building and
i think it was charlie who suggested
maybe wrong
i don't know but it's it's obviously
somewhat arbitrary
but uh but 10 was from
his perspective and it still is as i
understand it
well above the likely number
that would come in at least in the early
years
suggested 10 we put it in we went to a
24-0
vote i don't know whether that
limitation brought some people in who
would have voted against it or not i
actually don't know
but we had we had we had total consensus
on the bill
with all its parts put it forward
so i'm with chad with the brush
your expression um i think we know that
there's been
good interest but not people rushing in
to say we want to have a sports book
location and
they're also watching not only what we
do here in new hampshire
legislatively what's happening in
massachusetts
i think they've got a sports betting
bill
uh so it's always a threat
that
represent names that's
a that's a good point
there wasn't there isn't super division
i think we should it's a legitimate
topic to discuss
absolutely well i think the whole
the whole situation about charitable
gaming
has to be looked at under a
whole new a whole new microscope to be
honest with you
the thing has become much much more than
was ever anticipated ever
i mean this is not the church hall where
uh team number two conducts the games on
thursday night
that's right you know but they go with
bingo with all those volunteers
good morning everyone and welcome to the
committee of conference on
house bill 315. i'm
chair of the science technology energy
committee in the house
on the committee of conference with me
today is the vice chair of our committee
representative doug thomas
representative michael harrington
and representative jackie kelly pitts
for the senate we have representative
ken kevin
senator senator senator i'm sorry
senator kevin art who is chair of this
senate energy natural resources
and senator david waters is also a
member there
so we're ready to begin our
deliberations on hb 315
and the house would like to suggest
that we would be willing to proceed from
our
recommendation of non-concurrence and
a seed to the changes that the senate
made
to the bill but the senators find that
position acceptable
we do and just just thank you for their
good process it was a hard one to know
[Laughter]
okay then we have a consensus that the
house
proceeds to the changes the senate made
the hospital 315.
do you need a motion no i don't think
thank you no we have to wait because i
have to file the uh
video conference report senator
jeff bradley was my first champion
really so we go back that far
and the yankee things he would ban a
stone he didn't use the devil he said
the yankee fan had someone said
so i will ask for a motion to return the
thank you everybody for saying all right
you